have a bunch of credit card debts that
are cramping your cash flow it's not
easy managing lots of different terms
payments and interest rates you might
find yourself wondering if you should
streamline by consolidating them
together in a new credit card with a
juicy introductory rate sounds tempting
but there's a big catch you need to look
out for some of these offers involve
deferred interest which means that
you're still acre interest on your
balance during the promotional period
even though you don't see it when it
expires you are charged all of that
accumulated interest despite what you've
already paid this is especially
prevalent with cards offered by
retailers so read that fine print to
make sure you're really getting some
relief for more financial info check out
two cents on
YouTube